I can't imagine being a common sense
human being in September 2022 and not
understanding that brand is built on
social I I genuinely mean that I mean I
don't you know you'd have to be so
subconsciously religious about what you
were taught in college about how brands
are built to be anyone that doesn't see
it so I love when people like Gary TV
works for me I'm like you spent six
million dollars on that campaign
I'm like it should work that's why most
brands are losing
they're wrong you're absolutely right
you know like I I can't imagine being a
common sense human being
in
September 2022 and not understanding
that brand is built on social
I I genuinely mean that I mean I don't
you know you'd have to be so
subconsciously
religious about what you were taught in
college about how brands are built to be
anyone that doesn't see it and so My
Philosophy is why would you spend money
on something if you can spend less money
to achieve the same goal
so I love when people like Gary TV works
for me I'm like you spent six million
dollars on that campaign
I'm like it should work I'm like the
question is did you spend six million
dollars
on creative and media
in Tick Tock YouTube Facebook Pinterest
influencers podcast like YouTube like
what would happen if you actually spent
that same money perfectly in the
Contemporary environments and so you
know
it's weird because I've been on this
journey for 15 years
um
and I was incredibly empathetic the
first seven years because I knew people
didn't know
but I literally have dinners now with
decision makers who will spend the first
30 minutes talking about how social
media can completely controls their
child's life
then they'll spend the next 15 minutes
talking about politics and how social
media needs to be regulated because of
how powerful it is as a proxied against
democracy and then we'll transition into
talking about selling cereal and makeup
and they don't think social media can
move the needle I'm like so let me get
this straight you think this platform is
so powerful that we need to regulate it
because it could put democracy on its
knees but you don't think it can sell
cereal
and so you know my point of view is that
it's the most underpriced
macro platform to get actual consumption
it's also a place if you understand it
well that really addresses the elephant
in the room which is the elephant in the
room in marketing today is that
creative's too expensive
and because it's too expensive you can't
actually
get the full advantage of the media
opportunities that exist if it costs you
too much to make creative you're not
going to make 87 pieces of creative a
day to distribute against 35 different
consumer segmentations against 21 social
platforms
you'll never do that you can't
and so
yeah I mean to me in 2022 it's kind of
an exhausting conversation
to even like like I'm struggling to get
going to even be in the combo because I
can't understand how people don't see it
the only thing that makes sense to me is
when people are in corporations and the
internal scoring system doesn't justify
it then I understand you're trying to
protect your job and you should you have
a mortgage and a family but if we're
talking real life like human beings like
our kids health depends on the results
how you don't understand that this is
the place that Brand's built I don't
know this is Facebook Twitter and Tumblr
stock I made a very big bet 15 years ago
where I took every dollar I had in the
bank and invested in three companies
Facebook Twitter and Tumblr obviously
that changed the course of my life
but the funny story of why I'm pointing
here it's actually the answer to your
question when I invested in Tumblr I
called my brother and I said AJ Tumblr
is going to be bigger than Facebook and
Twitter it's gonna be the biggest one of
them all and he said why and I said
because Facebook and Twitter you follow
people Tumblr you follow things you're
interested in
and so even back then I was fascinated
by the interest graph over the social
graph now that didn't become true
because there's a lot of other variables
to why a company will be successful
including who's operating it but
what is true is that what Tick Tock has
tapped into in the last three years
has completely changed
and will change everything we're all
doing and is the answer to your question
the way it's changed is the following
now not now art not math is the most
important equation in doing creative on
social the algorithms now reward
retention more than ever which means
they're going to show you things you
want
right
things you want are far more predicated
on the creative than the math that gets
them in front of you
instead of the Facebook environment we
all grew up with where you could get in
front of the people you wanted to based
on great data and then you would pound
them with advertising
what we need to win on now is creative
that is advertising that is educating or
entertaining AKA creating consideration
then once that is proven then we can
convert Those ads to Performance ads but
we have to start with the creative
instead of what everybody here knows
which is the creative has been a
secondary
part of the equation which is why we
spend 80 percent of our money on the
media and 20 on the creative
and as many people here know people
haven't really been doing marketing and
branding they've been doing sales if you
look at the creative of the DTC Brands
over the last 15 years it's much more
couponing and and and newspaper
advertising than it is marketing that
has completely changed in the last three
to four years and everybody here has to
leave with two things one we need to
actually get into the creative business
and make things that people want to
watch two we need to make it for many
different consumer segmentations this is
not television where you make a piece of
vanilla and you hope that everybody on
Earth wants it this is Baskin Robbins
and we need to make a lot of different
flavors and go up and then see the
common ground and then understand what
our brand stands for based on 37
different consumer segmentations of
relevance once you can understand the
upside down model of how brands are
built because the internet now rules not
the television
then you can really start to understand
what to do web 3.0
um is really slang for the consumer
blockchain
and why the brands should care about it
is if they are a brand
that does not want to transact on their
business AKA sell it
in the next five years then they should
really care because it's 1999 2000 all
over again
and 2005 internet was a hell of a lot
more important than 99 internet and 2000
what are we in 22 and 2027 nfts are
going to matter a hell of a lot more
than 2022 nfts so
why you have to care is it is my deep
belief that what I saw the internet do
to communication starting in 1996 and
being in every day is exactly what the
consumer blockchain is about to do for
transaction
that everybody here thinking about first
party data sustainable e-commerce with
high cost shipping AKA how do we get
people into memberships and monthly and
and packages instead of one-off skus and
a million other things that you think
about day to day the blockchain's better
at solving it than the internet most
people even in this room which is which
I highly respect and this is not a Razz
this is being empathetic that people are
busy and haven't had the time to spend
50 hours on it most people even in this
room haven't really synthesized their
strategies on the fact that the internet
is different from the blockchain
and if you haven't done that then you
don't even understand the functionality
of the blockchain and how do I know this
because it's what happened with people
in The Logical real world were unable to
do with the internet
when I was pitching wine library.com in
1996 literally everybody who I talked to
said to me who would ever go on the
internet to buy a bottle of wine I can
go to the store and get it and my
response was everyone
and so what what and that blew people's
[ __ ] mind in 1996 right because we
still had people and you all know this
almost every single person on this calls
parents
was scared to put a credit card into a
computer in 1999.
and so what we're seeing now with
people's fear like most people in this
room that [ __ ] on nfts if they do don't
realize that they've become their
parents
right they're they're demonizing a
technology without fully understanding
it
and so for me I actually think nfts are
going to be one of the most significant
Innovations in cpg land because when I
see nfts my brain goes to LTV
it goes to retention
it goes to event marketing it goes to
monthly subscription it goes to
how I'm going to control first party
data and not be at the mercy of Google
Facebook and Tick Tock when you do your
50 hours things get real different real
fast and that would be my takeaway here
you know unfortunately we just ended
this summer where you probably could
have snuck it in but if you're listening
and you understand the macro of what I'm
saying please use
the winter holidays to really actually
actually read on what a blockchain does
how it is a ledger that affirms a
transaction that nobody on Earth can
alter and what impact that has and then
you are the currency I am the central
bank to be friends I collect the
royalties I have the affirmation I'm not
at Mercy of any technology stack or
government stack this is a big deal it's
a big deal but it's internet 1996 and
people are glossing over it especially
because we have the internet this time
last time we didn't even have the
internet yet so it's a very important
very important technology that I think
can really matter especially for some of
the creative people here who are
interested in General Mills or the Leo
Burnett era of the 60s where you create
characters and the value of those
characters like I'm very into that and
so if you're if you know there's a very
big reason I'm passionate about this
technology I understand the macro of the
transaction thing to the communication
thing I just referenced I'm also highly
affected by character development the
Marlboro Man Keebler elves things of
that nature and I I see nfts as a
substantial
playground for that these characters you
see back here my Disney be friends I
fully intend to building a multi-billion
Dollar cpg business that looks like
Fruity pal bills or Mary Ruth's Organics
or things of that nature what why I'm
very empathetic for so many people being
confused is I live in this every day and
I've been watching it since 2017 quietly
when when crypto kitties hit and like
I've been watching and waiting for my
timing of the entry which obviously was
about 18 months ago
the reality is ninety percent of the
people that were in it last year were
there for the quick buck and that DNA is
very off-putting to people that are in
things for so unlike the internet which
it was in 95 and 6 where the crew was a
bunch of nerds that nobody fully
understood what the hell they were
talking about
that's one version of like a niche that
you gotta kind of like understand how to
use this one was very difficult because
there was so much money involved and get
rich quick and scams and like all the
worst Dynamics more like extreme Wall
Street Dynamics which is why we had
Internet stock issues in the 90s
and then on top of everything else you
have social media so you have all these
people gloating hey I bought a donkey
with a cigar up its ass and made 400 000
what normal human being thinks that's a
good thing
and so I was very empathetic to the
confusion I continue to be empathetic to
the confusion
but let there be no confusion
the consumer blockchain is the biggest
invention since the internet and every
person in this room is going to be
highly affected by it because all of you
will pay your taxes and buy future homes
on it so you better figure it out
because when you made fun of your mom
for not using email or a smartphone
you're literally about to be that person
with the blockchain in the next decade
so I highly recommend you figure it out
I do think believe it or not the luxury
brands are a little bit ahead because
they're thinking about loyalty and
retention what you're seeing from lvmh
and others in my opinion without knowing
everything that they're thinking but
watching carefully I do think they have
a sense of wait a minute this is an
opportunity for us to create communities
things like Amex Black Card like I I see
certain nuances there so if I was to
tell you all to look I'm always scared
at this early of a stage to say go look
at Puma because it's really hard to
understand what it all means what I
would say is get grounded in the
underlining technology then you can do
your damage you'll understand how it
works for you the problem is when I look
at internal teams across the board
it's a pretty bad sich because most
people are mailing it in and they're
either blindly DTC and want it to be
sales and that's how the creatives being
justified or if they're even flirting
with creative
they just think the 24 year old knows
what to do on Tick Tock and so they're
not even evaluating it so we have an
acronym internally at Vayner called sock
strategic organic content and all day
long I just walk around on slack email
and in the halls and say it's the s
in sock that everything lives and dies
by here which means do you actually know
how to make creative for Pinterest
versus LinkedIn versus YouTube shorts
versus Tick Tock and that is creative
strategy and platform strategy and
understanding attention and culture at a
PhD level
and yet most people just mail in their
social and they care about all this
other stuff their brand and billboards
and Remnant TV and I'm just watching
this landscape and so a to drive down
cost there are plenty of 22 to 30 year
olds you can hire that will give you a
better cost basis that are very capable
of producing the content but you need
somebody at the top that understands the
s in sock Like A Champion or the whole
thing's a waste or B
I believe we're 24 months away because
I'm in this business we have gotten so
far ahead of everybody in the last 24
months
in Fortune 500 land that there are now
copycat agencies or the big companies
are starting to take the creative
seriously and are looking to drive down
costs get away from 300 000 videos for
television and getting into two hundred
thousand dollars a month of creative but
making 650 pieces of creative that are
meaningful for brand and sales and so
I'm starting to see the market go there
so
finding someone who does it for real for
real like for a lot of mid-tier Brands
piggyback Brands really spending forty
to fifty thousand dollars a month on
Creative that really builds brand to
many different consumer segmentations
but also shows
organic virality which then become your
performance ads is where a lot of brands
are going to go whereas they're mailing
in that fee right now and they'd rather
spend it on media dollars but their CAC
numbers are going through the roof
because iOS 14.5 came along and changed
the game and there's just a lot going on
in the Tactical operational side
by the way influencers
really focusing on micro influencers
because you get content and distribution
uh being smarter about your partnership
deals
like if you're going to do a partnership
get at all costs getting content out of
the system and not having creatives that
think about ideas but having creatives
that think and make I'll give you a
great comp people always like Gary but
how do I know Tick Tock will be here in
five years I'm like well when you bought
trillion dollar commercials on Seinfeld
you weren't trying to guess when they
were going to end the show
right you didn't like you didn't need
NBC to promise you that friends would
play Forever you just bought ads on
Friends when the attention was on
Friends
so for me I'm on emotional I don't give
a [ __ ] about Tick Tock Facebook YouTube
Instagram could care less if they all
disappeared off the face of the Earth
I'd be pumped because all that attention
would have to go somewhere and I think
most people would struggle to figure out
where and that's my favorite thing to do
right so I would say a couple things
number one
it's more about like knowing if
something resonates is the most common
sense thing in the world if you're a DTC
brand you can literally see it if you're
asking for call to actions and if you're
doing it for Branding the qualitative
comments show you
one of the reasons I'm obsessed with
social creative is not only does it
build brand and give me a framework to
be able to build relevance at scale it's
also the single greatest consumer
insights machine of all time
but back to the essence sock 25 of the
creative that I personally in my brand
and what Vayner does that I put out is
strictly made to get insights of
curiosity of hypotheses I have about the
consumer
literally it is made to get the comments
so that I can build on the hypothesis to
create affirmation to create better
content
and so
it's the most common sense thing on
earth to know if it's working you see it
in the comments and you see it in the
sales if you choose to make it more of a
sales DNA
it's a hell of a lot easier to know if
your social creative is resonating than
if you're television or sponsorship is
resonating when we did television broad
everybody saw our [ __ ] vanilla
when you do relevance at scale in this
environment fewer people cross over and
seeing the different contexts
it was the reverse everybody saw your
Heineken ad and if it didn't resonate to
them which oh by the way it didn't to 90
because everything
is vanilla when it's in a 30 second
video because it has to be because it
has to do everything for everybody in
such a short period of time
so ironically we're in a let we're in a
place now where we can everybody always
goes to fear oh schizophrenia I go to we
used to sell vanilla and hope that 10
gave a [ __ ] now we can sell on relevance
and have a lot more people care about
our Brands what has happened in business
is everyone has gotten so infatuated
with scale
and efficiencies that we don't amortize
out the actual value so for me
and it's so funny that John just joined
I don't know if you guys see him on
screen or if I'm only here but if you
see do you guys see him
so jamo like held he heads up all of
Boehner's philosophy on media investment
and so we talk about day trading
attention and all things we talk about
all the time but if you ask jamo and I
what is our favorite thing that we're
working on kind of in our secret lab
because we're the weird ones is a
scalable human infrastructure that has
17 employees that work all day to be
able to reach out to every single person
on social and be able to price them out
and if they are a good buy at 850 to do
a influencer ad then it's a good buy if
they're four thousand bucks and they
charge 8.50 and it costs us 27 an hour
to execute we're in but nobody wants
overhead on unscalable right and so like
scaling the humans is the most
interesting thing for me right now and
so when we talk about it's the biggest
thing one of the reasons I'm ultra
confident about building be friends is
I'm right now building that
infrastructure so that people are every
YouTube family on Earth is opening up
the toys and the trading cards every
cool person is wearing the hoodies and
the t-shirts at massive scale to me
everyone became infatuated with working
media
and became one dimensional CAC in LTB
monsters and are overpaying for
awareness and I'm looking to win on
depth and scaling the unscalable and so
influencers at scale are really
interesting because nobody everyone's
focused on Gross versus net the net
result of your cost of getting an
influencer that you paid four thousand
dollars for that is worth twenty six
thousand is remarkable because you get
the content and the media distribution
but you also get the word of mouth and
the cosine and the endorsement and the
long tail affinity
foreign
[Music]